ブーブー言葉もっ 英語ってねフランスで英語ってしゃべらなかった
さからないですよね
私たちが行った時も英語なんかしゃべるん
この人口真似でサバーとかサバーと言った 意味わかってるのとか言った
よくないけどサバって言っておけばいいみたいよ
なんかゲームゲームみたいな
無事にそれをくぐり抜けて今だってよかった
やすこさんの寄宿舎のルーティンもすごく厳しかったですもんねお話伺ったら
朝かしらね私はそうともそれ9 c なんか思わなくてね
全然嫌でもなんでもなかったんだけど
赤ワイン飲んだって言うことによって言ったら
へへへ
いろいろお水があまり良くないから赤ワイン皆さんね
カワインとか飲んでましたね
あのももも当然カトリックの学校だからフランスでしたから
だからあの朝起きた時にあの声をカランカランとかゆかねがお廊下でね
シスターがおならしになるとパッと外へあの寝巻きのまんま出て
お廊下に依存が続くんですよまず
うーん
そうそういうそういう生活をずっとやってて
全然それがもう当然だと思ってたの私は
ただ本当に最近なのよ厳し厳しかったのねとかって言われるのは
本当最近なんですよ私はそれは全然普通だと
普通というか嫌だと思ったことはなかった
その生きのまま外に出るのはちゃんといるかいないかっていうのの確認になるのか?
でももしれなくて同時に朝のお祈りをするから
なるほど廊下に出てみんなでそこでまずお祈りをする
初めの朝起きてお祈りをして
それでまたドア閉めて
マトレスを今度ひっくり返さなきゃいけなくてね
それを目にいらっしゃるのもまたいついつ
マトレスを毎回ひっくり返すんですか?
うん
こういう風に
ええ
今考えれば厳しかったですね学校はね
へぇー
集団生活?
でも歴史さんなんて言いますか?
スペイン語聞いてて覚えたわけでしょ?
学校ではスペイン語ない?
うん
いやスペイン語のクラスはあったけど
やっぱり週一回みたいな
なときのあのトライリングはあるよね
スペイン語も喋れるんだ
いやいやいや
パパがスペイン語だから
スペイン語、日本語すごい
日本語と日本語だけど
いやいやいやいや
特にスペイン語に
聞いて少し分かる
一匹はどの言葉を聞いてても分かるんですか?